but they can't even go to Lightspeed no
they'd run out of fuel then why don't we
go faster than they're going
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh it's right there
that's pretty good pretty good
girls complete chewy no one only Walter
oh damn you got this
[Music]
this is gonna be you just getting up
you're about to say something and you
just keep getting thrown down if you
want to make you yell every time you can
[Music]
we have a way of tracking speed oh okay
thing me being so powerful I could sense
that or maybe read the report on your
desk every what's the resistance yeah
the symbol is the rebel okay but first
you could say he was stuck to the floor
what is a Jedi's favorite desserts ob1
cannoli
game grumps yeah I love them you don't
have long we'll just use that for now
when you walk in okay he really does
look like yeah I heard uh uh Chris's
voice is pretty good yeah that's here
let's see what's the line it says I'm
gonna show you the dark side yeah screw
those seeds are there chatting with each
other just wanna be like so what are you
doing
I have stories for the catalog have you
seen bad lip reading yes I love those
bad lip reading come push them all the
way say hey yeah three things go get
your mother on it
ditch the pointless mask and we'll cut
there okay I guess obviously we getting
it that we got in the stuff like that
so is Jimmy I find the same spaces yeah
we can get a yeah yes Jim walk into let
me make sure
[Music]
[Laughter]
so no I got a girl's okay quiet on the
set and no I got a friend shit to do
speaking of which where's that douchebag
from girls hey
three things go kill your mother yeah go
ahead
yeah I like you know I don't have an odd
eye but like keep it on your neck there
okay he's stuck man really it's like
every time I hear him out I'm in the
middle choke I'm just hoping to can of
worms Chris and Malcolm oh I got stuck
in the middle
Walter does the best man it is right my
cousin but that's yeah I can only think
of that one company or my holy jingler
yeah that's cool I like that tell me
again why we're not firing them there to
out of rage but they can't even gonna
like me
no they'd run out of fuel then why don't
we go a little faster than they're going
look we only have three settings on this
ship that was amazing one more like that
tell me again why we're not firing at
them
[Applause]
it picks up the last line this is the
last one for real this time
yes tell me again why we're not firing
at them
then why don't you want evil or
efficiency you just go loudly or quietly
it will do one quiet in one ear Malcolm
and silver ones you want evil or
efficiency you just focus okay Bonnie
[Music]
Chris do you want evil or efficient well
evil
it looks like he's at the end so after
well Evo of course if you could go back
alright so so so yeah you want evil or
efficient will evil of course go over
anything it's just going to keep doing
that yeah yeah
do you watch evil or efficient well the
evil of course great okay and this one
you do you do you want evil or efficient
well evil of course and then just like
we just say when we suck
I like hashtag trump 2017 the evil or
efficient he's real
[Music]
we probably suck get one more yell we
suck oh come on you're ready I'd be
proud head back okay that's you 145 the
other direction
don't know because he'll just reverse it
it flows yeah we pretty much think these
are the versions of the Little Mermaid
poster version oh it's Snoke is making
up for something yeah overcompensate
later it has the Hugh Hefner I really
wanted bunny ears on there's just this
Imperial bride no just wants to use
protection
we're next let's see that
and look at look at that tattoo it hell
yeah this movie ever favorite oh god why
just because it's the movie that made me
want to be a filmmaker
well you need something better
oh I didn't see the camera turns oh
that's cool I don't think I saw Santa's
here I saw starfox or something
well well what's on the other side oh
yeah it works have you ever seen that
it's it's so funny there's a video where
somebody takes lines from the starfox
and mashes it up to have like these
horrible conversations no like what like
slippies like hey Falco he's like I'm
coming for you slippy a little closer
[Laughter]
what yeah back when I played starfox I
didn't have dialogue at all it was near
it sounds general Peppers but perfect
English yeah wake up like this this sexy
lot of details there
where did you get the big deformed piece
from Jim uh mrs. halls like spirit
Halloween makeup kits really yeah just
kind of uh cut up and put together and
I've got some sculpting wax here for
blend it in a little bit
sulfur dogs review' of the band without
a face you're working off the picture
over there yeah this picture of jigsaw
[Laughter]
we're going for the Hugh Hefner look you
said with the you gotta walk like you're
six foot nine okay great
alright go ahead cut it and here you're
gonna do kind of a same shot you did
with phasma Rob with tracking outcomes
holding up cheeky wait until he looks
over should be like when he did was fine
I believe you Oh Hugh you win the wicked
luckily for the legs
[Music]
[Laughter]
okay now you have all the space you have
four minutes yep Lounge smoke we realize
that like bad family photo we did first
four so you need to be all like creepy
like yeah
[Applause]
she's here
[Laughter]
[Music]
like just cut in half yeah part was like
kind of hilarious
then his bottom half not the seat that
was dug and I started and applause that
was the one time in our probably the
only time in our life will ever starting
applause in a movie theater but we were
like the first to clap with it it was
just kind of done with smoke anyway so
we started applauding in the back of the
iMac skater and then everybody else
started abruptly time of my life I did
that you started it see you have it you
look down and not even like like
anything like they just to give me a
sense of backstory do i yeah when I said
after I say the line how do you think
you just like back and again just a bit
more angry like you know
hell even was I what it killed someone
to blah blah blah like even you're like
that's it like that was my character
that's all thank God bring up just a
hinge okay ready hmm and actor who the
hell even was I would it have killed
anyone to give me one sentence of
backstory sure I'll do one more on this
one just start off slowly looking down
like you know
- and then just who the hell was high
like you know sadly all the tape instead
of stabbing me in the back
why don't you give me a back story okay
it's a Superman Catholic Joey you just
place your non-plus oh oh okay so drop
crotch oh there you go we gotta keep our
gonna keep the tag
we'll see I'll just count - it's like a
chewy I really like a let's just paint
your hands Brown yeah
[Laughter]
with the hood double toasted oh yeah
yeah they're great
this is an official plug for double time
oh yeah it's one of my favorite websites
they're great really yeah let's go up
for that um hell yeah I want to check
them out Nealon person yes Patrick Gertz
did a voice for my Lloyd amazing holy
shit that scenes with you know he sounds
like the Charlie Brown adult
[Applause]
[Music]
come with me
yeah you can do that's fine with me
[Laughter]
this is the second time they're fighting
and join me join me and something splits
them apart I just realized that the last
yeah great
that's superlative ha ha ha
[Laughter]
sassy superlative hmm
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
ain't having your Imperial shit today
I'm going back to my ship okay
so so again so I just uh your your eyes
already OB just do the shoot
oh my god you got hold it for like a
good ten seconds
[Laughter]
super Leia just like I see you can pray
characters we don't need to learn
[Laughter]
you